hi i'm carla Gugino and I am here at
BuzzFeed to answer your burning
questions about the haunting of Hill
House okay so boiler alert if you have
not watched the show I need you to stop
watching immediately because we cannot
spoil anything for you you have to watch
this start to finish
for reals number 1 how does the Red Room
actually work is the house set up like a
maze like we see in the opening credits
well actually the set of Hill House was
the most extraordinary set I have ever
been on they built an actual two-story
house in which we could walk everywhere
in the house and in fact we did it all
in one take in Episode six which you
should see um so in fact the Red Room is
always in the same location in Hill
House it's just that it manifests
differently based on each person's
psyche so basically it provides a space
of solace for each person which is
different obviously for Olivia it's the
reading room you know for Theo it's a
dance room for Steve it's a game room
etc etc so the Red Room is actually
where it is all the time it's just that
you can't get in literally only in there
time seems to be happening all at once
in the show do you think that means
Olivia was able to watch her kids grow
up in some way absolutely she's been
watching the whole time I would say the
the scenes that you see evidence of that
are surely when she's grown up and she
has the model of the forever house in
her office and you see as she goes up
the stairs the lights blink as in come
home that's Olivia doing that and then
also when Olivia crawls out from behind
the desk and you see that she's
destroyed the forever house so she's
there with them
the whole time how much does the mold
have to do with people going crazy
inside Hill House very interesting
question the more mold there is the more
mental disintegration is happening for
sure so the the further we get from
reality and the more we start losing our
minds definitely metaphorically the
moment
growing so it is sort of seeping in and
taking over and it's inescapable as
black mold is I have to say for anyone
like just afraid of germs it was the
most terrifying part of the house
shooting with just seeing black mold
boozing up the walls when Luke sees
Olivia in a version of the Red Room did
he actually died and was she trying to
convince him to stay
so yeah Luke dies for a moment you know
how people do sometimes their heart will
stop and then they'll come back and
Olivia's pole is so strong and her love
for her son is so strong and of course
she thinks that she is saving him and
finally he is home but Nell is very
strong now too and so this is really a
battle of wills between the two of them
both of them fighting for what they
perceive to be Luke's life and
ultimately Nell was able to pull him
back to the real world did Olivia and
Nell die of their own volition or did
poppy and Olivia respectively kill them
both I think there's ultimately we came
to the place where I think there's no
question that neither of them would have
fallen to their deaths on their own
volition there had to be that tap from
you know Olivia in Elle's case or poppy
in Olivia's case that tap of someone who
had already crossed over the other side
that actually does push them so no he
has not of their own volition did Olivia
feel genuine remorse for killing Abigail
or was she too far gone to realize what
she had done for sure Olivia feels that
she is saving her children so initially
when abigail is going when you see her
frothing at the mouth when she is
actually gonna cross over
I think Olivia is dead set on the fact
that on the other side she will be at
peace but as you notice if you watch it
carefully or perhaps again when when
Olivia comes back up to the Red Room
again later and is truly devastated
because at that point she's in and out
of being taken over by the house and
trying to wake up just trying to be
there for her family trying to come back
at that moment when she sees Abigail she
is truly devastated and I think has no
recollection of what she's done why was
Olivia so taken with Poppy was it
because of the vanity Steve gave Olivia
yeah this is a more subjective answer
but since I played Olivia I will answer
it which is that I think poppy really
allowed Olivia in a moment where all of
she's so unsure of what to do and she's
getting so confused by the house and by
being affected so much by the house and
because of her migraines and all these
things she's just much more susceptible
than anyone else and she is a mother
bear at heart is that poppy really gives
her the assurance of a way in which she
can save especially the twins from this
horrible fate that she has foreseen
because she has gone ahead and she has
seen that one of them is having problems
with mental health and one of them is an
addict so she has seen this horrible
fate and she really is trying to save
them from it and so the horror genre is
a beautiful kind of way to allow us to
talk about a lot of very real things in
a heightened way so in that sense I
think poppy seems so assured that if she
does this thing the kids will be okay
and at that point she really believes
her why didn't the gasoline work in the
house this is when Luke comes in at the
end and lights it was that the ghost
protecting the house or something
greater that is actually specifically
Olivia so he comes to find his mom in a
lot of ways and she puts out the fire
you know because he's finally home for
her it's the happiest moment of her life
this is the last one who do you think
put the buttons on nails eyes in the
funeral home that also is because Olivia
knows how much now loved her buttons and
it's her way of sort of making now at
peace thank you so much for your
questions you guys asked such good
questions I'm so glad that that
Hillhouse is really resonating with you
is a very important and amazing
experience for us so so happy to be
sharing with you bye guys
[Music]
[Music]